[Musique]
elle a grandi dans une famille hâée de
gauche avant de se convertir au
catholicisme et c'est sa foi qu'il a
amené à s'engager en politique jusqu'à
devenir porte-parole du rassemblement
[Musique]
national bonjour Mathilde Paris bonjour
alors vous êtes aujourd'hui déput du
rassemblement national du Loiret j'ai
donc été assez surpris de découvrir que
après le 21 avril 2002 quand Jean-Marie
Le Pen s'est qualifié pour le second
tour de la présidentielle vous êtes venu
à Paris exprès pour manifester contre
Jean-Marie Le Pen contre le le Front
national à l'époque pourquoi écoutez moi
j'étais pas du tout dans à l'époque de
de ce milieu-là puisque j'ai grandi dans
une famille de gauche comme vous l'avez
dit et que pour moi à cette époque le FN
et Jean-Marie Le Pen c'était clairement
un danger pour pour la République
française et notamment avec ses ses
déclarations qu'il avait pu tenir par le
passé donc il y avait voilà une une peur
comme beaucoup de Français à l'époque
euh après je concède que je ne
connaissais pas bien non plus le
mouvement de l'Intérieur euh j'en avais
voilà une vision extérieur comme
beaucoup et qui était euh rédiibitoire
et qui faisait que à aucun moment je
n'aurais pensé un jour euh finalement
euh rejoindre ce parti avec Marine Le
Pen alors vous êtes pas tout de suite
engagé hein euh votre premier engagement
politique remonte à 2009 ce n'était pas
pour le Front national à l'époque vous
avez pris votre carte au MPF le
Mouvement pour la France de Philippe de
Villier alors vos grands-parents
maternels et votre maire était de gauche
je crois que votre maèire a même fait
partie des Jeunesses communistes tout à
fait comment est-ce qu'ils ont vécu
votre votre engagement au au MPF à
l'époque alors le MPF quand même ça
passait mieux que que le FN clairement
mais c'est sûr que c'était c'était pas
tout à fait du tout sur les mêmes les
mêmes la même la même idée politique he
qu'on avait ils vous en ont voulu ça a
créé des des disputes ça alors je dirais
pas que ça a créé des disputes mais plus
de l'incompréhension et puis euh bah
c'est vrai que mon grand-père surtout
bah était un peu attristé de se dire bah
mince
elle est partie de l'autre côté quoi
donc mais voilà
après pour autant je veux dire c'était
quand même il savait que j'étais ni
raciste ni voilà donc ça il le savait il
savait qui j'étais et donc là-dessus je
pense qu'il sétait quand même rassuré
vous êtes donc passé en quelques années
bah d'une manifestation contre
Jean-Marie Le Pen a un engagement pour
Philippe dev Villier euh qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé entre les deux pour opérer
une telle bascule politique alors il y a
eu un événement important c'est je suis
partie en fait aux États-Unis en tant
que étudiante voilà je suis partie en
immersion dans une famille d'accueil
j'ai fait le lycée américain et ça a été
un peu un électrochoc pour moi d'être
bah loin de la France et j'ai pris
conscience à ce moment-là bah de ce que
c'était d'être français finalement quel
était notre héritage quelle était la
richesse cette richesse patrimoniale
historique de not notre pays notre
culture notre art de Vire tout ce qui
faisait finalement notre notre identité
propre et j'ai pris conscience que
finalement en tant que Français on
navait pas cette notionl que on nous l'a
donnait sûrement pas suffisamment que
soit à l'école ou ou dans le cercle le
familial et et et je me suis dit c'est
pas possible aujourd'hui qu'on qu'on ait
pas conscience en France que la jeunesse
de France n'est pas conscience de la
chance qu'elle a finalement d'être
française de de la richesse qui est ce
pays et et pour laquelle il faut se
battre alors il y a un autre événement
qui a bouleversé le cours de votre vie
pendant cette même période c'est votre
conversion au catholicisme vous
expliquez que la la religion vous a aidé
à à traverser une épreuve personnel si
j'en parle c'est parce que vous faites
le lien aussi entre votre conversion au
catholicisme et votre engagement
politique pourquoi bien ça a été euh
enfin voilà très clairement Mo j'ai j'ai
failli mourir j'aiétaéis anorexique j'ai
j'ai pas peur de le dire euh et si voilà
si j'avais pas eu cette conversion je
pense que sera je serais tout simplement
plus de ce monde et ça a été j'ai
tellement reçu si vous voulez que j'ai
eu ce besoin de me donner en fait de me
donner aux autres et le meilleur moyen
de servir pour moi c'était l'engagement
politique et et là ça a été
effectivement bah mon
adhésion au au Front national de
l'époque lorsque marine est arrivée à à
la tête du parti donc ça ça s'est fait
en en 2011 vous le dites he ça
correspond au moment où prend la
présidence du du parti ou tout à fait
j'ai franchi le cap suite à l'arrivée de
marine et c'est ça c'est ça qui vous a
convaincu de rejoindre le front national
c'est ce changement de de présidence on
va dire tout à fait parce que pour moi
marine clairement elle avait fait le
ménage dans le parti pour justement
enlever tous les toutes les personnes
qui avaient des profils sulfureux et qui
qui posaient clairement pour moi un
problème et puis voilà elle était son
discours vraiment pour moi me
satisfaisait et elle avait cet équilibre
finalement où je me retrouve aussi par
rapport à mon histoire grandi dans une
famille de gauche un équilibre entre
voilà un aspect quand même social
important chez elle c'est elle a
vraiment une fibre sociale et en même
temps la fibre voilà de de défendre ce
que c'est que la la France nos idéaux
nos valeurs et de fil en aiguille vous
avez fini par vous présenter aux
élections municipales à Blois en 2014
vous avez été élu conseillère municipal
puis conseillère régional en 2015 vous
avez échoué au législatif de 2017 dans
le Loir etcher et 5 ans plus tard vous
avez été élu dans le Loiré et en
parallèle de tout cela bah vous avez eu
une carrière professionnelle vous étiez
en charge du messénat au château de
chambor à quel moment est-ce que la la
politique a pris le dessus sur cette
carrière
professionnelle on va dire que
vraiment le le déclic je dirais ça a été
dans les années
2017-28 plus voilà j'ai donné naissance
à mon 3è enfant et clairement ça
devenait très compliqué de gérer à la
fois une vie politique une vie familiale
et une vie professionnelle en tant que
salarié avec des horaires enfin voilà un
rythme quand même assez
euh strict on va dire et et et ça
devenait vraiment pour moi difficile de
tout mener de front et donc à ce
moment-là j'ai décidé de créer ma propre
entreprise que je me voyais pas non plus
faire que de la politique j'ai toujours
été comme ça j'ai toujours eu besoin
d'avoir quelque chose à côté la suite
pour vous bah elle est directement lié à
Jordan Bardella parce qu'il vous a
d'abord nommé au bureau national du du
RN puis porte-parole du parti alors
porte-parole c'est c'est quand même
assez compliqué comme fonction à à
assumer faut faut être capable de
répondre à toutes les questions tous les
imprévus possibles est-ce qu'on vous a
un peu formé avant de vous de vous
lancer comme ça dans le dans le grand
bain alors formmer pas spécialement en
fait j'avais déjà eu il y avait une
formation une petite formation quand
j'étais membre du bureau national à
avant que que Jordan prenne la
responsabilité de la présidence du du du
mouvement mais après en fait c'est je
pense queil avait détecté que j'avais
quand même une aisance orale et j'avais
déjà fait forcément bah dans le cadre
des législatif on a tous été amenés à à
passer quand même un peu sur des
plateaux à un moment alors chaque porte
parole développe un peu son style il y
en a qui sont très punchur il y en a qui
peuvent être plus pédago pour expliquer
là on vous voit en photo avec
porte-parole du groupe RN Kevin mauvieux
c'est quoi vous votre style en tant que
porte-parole moi j'essaie de de parler
vraiment de la vraie vie des gens en
fait j'ai envie d'être vraiment ce
porte-voix de la ruralité parce que moi
je suis voilà j'habite dans un
territoire rural je le vis au quotidien
et pour moi c'est vraiment important de
donner une voix à tous ces invisibles de
la société française c'est vraiment ça
pour moi c'est être leur porte-voix
c'est ça qui me en 2015 tout juste élu
au au conseil régional euh il y a une
image qui a marqué un peu les médias
locaux vous êtes rendu à la première
session du du conseil régional avec
votre fille qui était toute petite à
l'époque et vous l'avez allaité pendant
la séance
c'était un un geste féministe pour vous
de faire ça c'était bah c'était pour moi
quelque chose de naturel je l'avais fait
aussi pour pour mon premier bébé j'étais
au conseil municipal à l'époque de Blois
et j'avais pris on vous voit en photo
dans une cérémonie officielle avec c'est
ça porte en écharpe en fait j'avais
l'habitude de porter tous mes bébés en
écharpe et puis de les allaitter les 6
premiers mois comme c'est recommandé et
pour moi c'est important en fait qu'en
tant que femme on veut aujourd'hui que
les femmes s'investissent en politique
on a fait beaucoup avec la parité sur
les listes électorales mais il faut
aussi queon puisse être pleinement pour
moi c'est indispensable qu'on accepte
qu'on puisse être pleinement mère
pleinement engagé dans nos mandats
électifs et et ça je pense que c'est
encore du mal à passer moi je me suis
pris des réflexions de la part de la
majorité de gauche d'ailleurs du du
conseil régional qui voyait d'un mauvais
œil en disant mais c'est pas le lieu et
cetera il fallait que je me cache et je
pense qu'on a encore beaucoup à faire
effectivement pour faire accepter que
bah une mère peut allater son enfants
dans l'espace public ou dans dans des
des assembbléiste pour vous c'est alors
je le fais pas forcément en me disant je
fais du militantisme féministe je le
fais pas pour ça mais c'est c'est une
forme de féminisme pour moi
effectivement vous avez un un collègue
du groupe RN qui bon partage visiblement
pas forcément votre conception de de la
place des femmes dans la société je
voulais vous faire réagir à ce qu'il a
dit c'était dans le cadre du débat sur
le projet de loi pour le plein emploi
nous nous partons du principe qu'une
mère au foyer et ben elle est peut-être
mieux à la maison à s'occuper de ses
enfants
plutôt et oui mais bien sûr n déplaise à
mes collègues plutôt que si elle le
souhaite il vaut mieux qu'elle reste à
la maison à s'occuper de ses enfants si
elle le souhaite plutôt qu'elle aille
chercher plutôt que vous l'envoyeer dans
un dispositif où elle va devoir réaliser
15 he de d'activité ça doit vous mettre
hors de vous quand vous entendez ça non
ça doit alors au début en fait parce que
j'ai eu que le début quand j'ai vu les
une petite polémique sur les réseaux
c'est vrai que j'ai un peu bondi après
j'ai mieux compris le contexte en fait
c'est par rapport aux heures de RSA
qu'on voulait imposer aujourd'hui les
heures de de servicees public qu'on
voulait imposer il répond de façon
spontanée et puis qu' se reprend après
en ou là là j'ai peut-être dit une
bêtise là alors je pense c'était surtout
de la maladresse de sa part
effectivement il s'agit pas de d'imposer
aux femmes de rester au foyer je pense
qu'on est beaucoup à être très content
d'avoir une vie à côté et que c'est un
source d'épanouissement aussi pour nous
alors en 2014 vous avez qualifié
l'avortement de crime contre l'humanité
en le comparant au mécanismees mise en
place par l'idéologie naz ce sont les
les thmes que vous aviez employé à
l'époque vous avez fait aussi partie des
33 députés qui ont voté contre la
constitutionnalisation du du droit à à
l'IVG on peut être féministe et
s'opposer au au droit des femmes à
disposer de leur corps c'est alors pour
moi enfin je je réfute le terme droit
des femmes à disposer de leur corps euh
parce que si vous voulez pour vous l'IVG
c'est pas bah il y a un il y a un être
humain en construction hein quand même
donc on n'est pas seul dans cette
histoire je pense que c'est important de
le rappeler euh moi je m'inscris plus si
vous voulez dans la ligne de Simon ve je
pense que personne ne dira que Simon ve
était était antiéministe était contre le
droit des femmes aujourd'hui le le droit
à l'avortement a été complètement dévoyé
puisquelle elle avait mis des des
gardesfous et c'était important pour
elle que ça soit vraiment la solution de
dernier recours quand on avait étudié
toutes les solutions possibles pour
garder un enfant ce qui me choque c'est
qu'on ne fait rien pour aider les femmes
justement soit à avoir des moyens de
contraception parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
un vrai sujet il y a beaucoup de femmes
maintenant qui a une espèce de de de de
défiance vis-à-vis de la pilule de tous
les moyens de contraception donc
beaucoup de femmes finalement ne
n'utilisent plus ces moyens de
contraception qu'elles ont à leur
disposition et donc effectivement se
retrouve dans des situations compliquées
et puis je pense qu'il y a aussi la
question de la responsabilisation des
des hommes hein parce que un bébé on le
fait jamais toute seule et je crois que
bah souvent on élude aussi cette cette
partie-là parce que c'est évidemment la
femme qui derrière assume toutes les
conséquence seul très souvent et bien
d'un avortement et je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire si vous aussi
bien pour aider les femmes pour
responsabiliser les hommes et rien n'est
fait et je pense que justement cette
cette
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG ne va
absolument pas régler ses problèmes on
va passer un sujet plus léger on va
passer à notre quiz à présent je vais
vous proposer des débuts de phrases et
vous allez devoir les les
compléter avec Sandrine Rousseau je
partage alors je dirais pas grand-chose
peut-être la cause des femmes on a pas
tout à fait le même positionnement en
tout cas c'est a compris mais quand même
C ce combat féministe on va dire chacun
a sa façon dans mon camping-car je alors
je vais à la rencontre des habitants de
ma circonscription effectivement j'ai
choisi de faire une permanence mobile
donc je me déplace voilà chaque semaine
dans une commune différente de ma
circonscription qui est assez étendue he
elle fait il y a plus d'une heure de
route d'un bout à l'autre aujourd'hui
les les gens sont de plus en plus
méfiants vis-à-vis de la politique et
d'aller à leur rencontre de faire cet
effort d'aller de l'avant je pense que
c'est un moyen de faire de la politique
autrement et que c'est important enfin
entre porte-parole on se dit
souvent alors là vous parlez entre vous
j'imagine après les émissions oui ah bon
après
honnêtement globalement je pense
qu'entre porte-parole on est quand même
assez solidaire et on est sur la même
ligne il y a pas de souci merci beaucoup
math Paris d'être venu dans dans la
politique et
[Musique]
moi